in this segment we discuss a few
algebraic properties of the covariance
there is nothing deep here only some
observations that can be useful if we
want to carry out covariance
calculations we start by looking at this
quantity the covariance of a random
variable with itself so it's a special
case of this definition but where Y is
the same as X and therefore this second
term here is the same as the first term
and so what we're left with is the
expected value of the squared deviation
of the random variable from its mean and
we recognize that this is the same as
the variance of X so we conclude that
the covariance of a random variable with
itself is the same as the variance now
for the variance we had an alternative
formula which was often convenient in
simplifying variance calculations is
there a similar formula for the case of
the covariance let us start from the
definition and use linearity we have a
product here of two terms and we expand
that product to obtain four different
terms the expected value of the sum of
these four terms is going to be the sum
of their expectations so let us go
through the steps involved we have the
expected value of the product of this
term with that term gives us expected
value of x times y then we take the
expected value of the product of this
term with that term and because we have
a minus sign we put it out here and we
have the expected value of x times the
expected value of y inside the
expectation the next term is going to be
the product of this expected value with
Y and that gives us minus the expected
value of x times y and finally the last
term comes by multiplying this quantity
with that quantity and this is what we
have by applying linearity to the
definition of the curve
aryans now remember that the expected
value of a random variable is a number
it's a constant and constants can be
pulled outside expectations so if we do
that what we obtain is the following we
pull this constant outside the
expectation and we're left with the
expected value of x times the expected
value of y similarly for the next term
by pulling a constant outside the
expectation we obtain this expression
and finally for the last term we have
the expected value of a constant and
this is the same as the constant itself
we recognize here that the same term
gets repeated three times and because
here we have a minus sign we can cancel
this term with that term and what we're
left with is just the difference of
these two terms and this is an
alternative form for the covariance of
two random variables and this form is
often easier to work with
to calculate covariances compared with
the original definition let us now
continue with some additional algebraic
properties suppose that we know the
covariance of X with Y and were
interested in the covariance of this
linear function of X with Y what is the
covariance going to be to simplify the
calculations let us just assume zero
means although the final conclusion will
be the same as in the case of non zero
means so in the case of zero means the
covariance of two random variables is
just the same as the expected value of
the product of the two random variables
and using linearity this is the expected
value times a of x times y plus B times
the expected value of y now we assumed
zero means so this term goes away and
what we're left with
is a times the covariance of X with y so
we see that multiplying X by a increases
the covariance by a factor of a but
adding a constant has no effect the
reason that it has no effect is that if
we take a random variable and add the
constant to it the same constant gets
added to its mean and so this difference
is not affected as our final calculation
let us look at the covariance of a
random variable with the sum of two
other random variables again we assume
zero means and so the calculation is as
follows the covariance is the product of
the two random variables involved and
then we use linearity of expectations to
write this as the expected value of x
times y plus the expected value of x
times Z and we recognize that this is
the same as the covariance of X with y
plus the covariance of X with Z so in
this respect
covariances behave linearly they behave
linearly with respect to one of the
arguments involved